vancouver unfortunately i have to
reschedule there's a lot that goes on to
getting in and out of our countries and
until that's a little easier
i'm gonna have to postpone the vancouver
and the edmonton shows
um but
thursday march 3rd i will be at zany's
for one night only and friday march 4th
and saturday march 5th i'll be in
lexington get all your tickets at
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the hotty do y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media please if you're watching
the show please hit that subscribe
button it really helps us out a lot
means a lot to the show and it's a free
way to help all right also the patreon
every month
the patreon grows and every month we get
crazier and crazier stories yeah i told
you about the girl that had two [ __ ]
yeah i told you about the guy that died
that we that lives that we talked to
who's whose rib cage got shoved through
his back
have you heard that nah uh yeah i told
you about the guy that fell off a cliff
and had to spend what was it a day and a
half in the wilderness paralyzed these
are the stories a guy who who solved an
18 year old cold case who's doing that
in comedy me honeydew with you all it's
five bucks a month you sign up for a
year you're getting a month free you get
the honey do a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right come on out
and see me on tour uh the night pass
nation tour will be in nashville
tennessee march 3rd one night only march
4th and 5th lexington kentucky and uh
all tickets are available
ryanstickler.com all right that's the
deal right there you know we're doing
over here we highlight the low lights
these are the stories behind the
storytellers
beyond excited
waiting three years for this one to have
one of the best storytellers in the
world on the podcast finally ladies and
gentlemen the machine is here
burke chrysler welcome to the honeydew
it is good to be here and i should say
i'm in huntsville alabama asheville
north carolina i'm talking about roanoke
richmond norfolk i'm hitting the whole
east coast dude i'm doing shows in
baltimore i just like i don't know but i
just saw that and i added a night is it
the modell uh on
april 8th and april 9th i'm at the model
the lyrics that's where i was with tom
it's beautiful yeah that's that's the
theater in baltimore i started thinking
about doing a patreon can i tell you
like i got something happening something
shifted in me
um
where i i i used to [ __ ] put my whole
life on instagram i mean all of it my
kids
my house you knew every room in my house
you knew everything you knew my dog's
name you knew i you knew the street i
lived on i would i would bert's got new
lamp shades yeah yeah it was it was
crazy everything you did pillows and
then we got docs pretty heavily like
pretty aggressively like my phone number
my address
everything got out there
and it's all so easy anyway
for 20 you can get everyone [ __ ] yeah
yeah i i had to get a new phone number
and we bought a new house and i am super
nervous about putting [ __ ] out there
like i like for the first time in my
life i'll instagram but there's only
like two places on instagram in my house
like i don't feel and so i was thinking
about doing a patreon
where it was my instagram stories or
finding a patreon and then putting you
on like a different thread on my
instagram because i enjoy instagramming
i enjoy because it gets me out of my
like head sometimes like if i wake up
with an anxiety attack
if i put an instagram story like this
morning there's a perfect example watch
this this is this is last night
partied a little bit uh
did a podcast with brian simpson we put
back a bottle of whiskey yeah party a
little bit he's just on he's [ __ ]
he's great dude
so i wake up i'm a little bit like
i'm a little bit out of it i'm like [ __ ]
i'm just uh
i don't like i'm like what i what am i
gonna do just sit on my phone and i go
get up and if i do an instagram story
then i'm held accountable so then my
instagram story is
let's get to it today right so
i sit i sit and i say i'm going to work
out i know that if i put it up there i
go to work out i go and then i i kind of
put my day out there and i go i'm going
to work out i'm going to sauna i'm going
to polar plunge i got adr at 11. i got a
podcast at three i kind of put my day
out there and it gets me it it get it
gets me to do it and so but but it's i
have been weird about it so i was
thinking about patreon
it's it's been great i i just
i
also it's not i'm not trying to toot my
own horn or anything but i've always
been able to i can talk to anybody you
know what i can listen to anybody i
can't that's the difference i can't i
can listen to anybody i don't know what
you just
said i believe
i have such i have such a problem
listening
when brian simpson's over my house he's
doing a podcast and he's the most like
and then at six i was put into foster
care all i think
is how does how would that affect burke
chrysler like that even like i don't
know if and maybe that's empathetic
listening where someone tells you
something you go but ask that why not
say that say oh my god here's that this
is how i would feel about you i had
amanda knox on my podcast and i told him
i
like if you hate me because of it i go
yeah you should hate me because of it i
don't [ __ ] hey that's a great story
check this one out
really and so innocent okay now i don't
need another rest keep going keep it
going when i was 22 years old i got
involved with the russian mafia here's
how it happened but
it's so [ __ ]
i can't help it man i think it is who
i've been my entire [ __ ] life if you
come if you if you open up uh uh
like uh we have a sponsor i forget
skylight frames i bought skylight frames
for all my friends
all our friends all our friends
so that i could put pictures of myself
in their houses
so that when i go to their house i get
excited to see i remember that vacation
yeah like
i could remember like when photos were a
thing and people go hey you should see
my photo album and then you'd be like am
i in any of these because i don't give a
[ __ ] about seeing it like i'm not that
person i was only looking at photo
albums if i was at a girl's house and i
knew like it led to you know some action
i'm like i'll [ __ ] flip through your
disney world [ __ ] that's that's an
old-school thing too there's like
there's that's gone and you'd be like
who's that yeah and then you want you'd
have a bat i'd write stories about
people in my head
but who's that not my cousin she lives
in uh north carolina and you're like
[ __ ] for real
yeah
i mean i [ __ ]
i was a person that could i was never
the guy that people were like you know
who got to set you up with bert you
would fall in love with her yeah i was
but and i was always the guy like i
always thought like and i remember
people i'm sure there's people but i was
like i'll never fall in love i'll never
fall in love and then i did all right
let's let's do this because here's what
i want to know
i know i said this to you outside you
know and not to parallel it but when
when brody passed and we all went to his
memorial before the comedians got up to
speak
his childhood friends
baseball coach guys that that he knew
got up and they called him stephen you
know that was the interesting part right
and we called him brody and
it dawned on me like oh yeah this guy
had a whole life before we ever met this
guy and and what i know of you like
your history is that it begins for me
and i think a lot of people in
entertainment is the van wilder yeah so
what i want to know is
before all that you know talk to me who
are you where are you from originally i
know you're florida but
you know how many brothers and sisters
talk to me about your parents because
you you still have everybody
alive yeah it's alive stuck on wood
i mean i'm so worried about where are
you born
born in st petersburg uh florida are you
youngest oldest only oldest typical
oldest two of how many two three three i
have two sisters okay one's like three
years younger than me two years younger
than me and then one's ten years younger
than me okay she was the same parents
same parents yeah she was a [ __ ]
mistake
my parents were building a house and
they didn't they definitely didn't plan
her because there was no room for it
there no one built a room for
another house and then she showed up and
it was building
they're like i guess you're gonna just
sleep without him
but i slept with my parents until i was
like 10. what maybe older in the same
bed in the same bed yeah i slept with my
parents until i was like
i mean i could i could every night i
could tell you i could tell you older
it would sound creepy but like i i would
say
i would definitely say 10 because i know
that we moved to that house at 10.
that's that's my stepson over there he
[ __ ] 6'5 still sleeping in his mom's
bed i mean i i have i have real anxiety
separation issues you slept in your
parents bed till you were at least 10 or
11. and they didn't be like 100 10
because i remember doing it when we
moved into our new house they didn't say
get the [ __ ] out of here were they kind
of like coaxing or they were just loving
like get in here i don't think my
parents might never like bert you should
probably go sleep in your own room my
parents didn't have
weren't like that that type of parent
didn't exist i mean it did but like most
parents back down didn't have like
curfews or like times you went to bed we
didn't have nap times we didn't have
bedtimes we stayed up i stayed up
i would stay up until like
midnight one o'clock and then just go
get in bed with my mom and dad and my
sister would be in there my youngest
sister would be in a crib in there i
mean we all and then as when we got our
new house we had so we lived in like a
redneck redneck neighborhood i mean i'm
sorry
born in st petersburg okay moved to
philly
for like the first
four five three years of my life
you had a little philadelphia for three
years oh my sister was born in philly oh
okay in bryn mawr and then my dad got a
job
uh my dad got a job and i got accepted
to law school in florida maybe or
something like that like he moved back
to florida i'm not good with i'm not
good with like details that don't
involve me
i wasn't making any decisions back then
it was a long for the ride i was like
whatever
uh
first great like first first
legit memories i have we live in this
place called river bend and temple
terrace uh met some friends patrick
fagan who's i've known my whole life
uh
this is back in florida this is in
florida we moved back florida
um
i remember
distinctly
being affected very young
by tornadoes and hurricanes like being
like
natural disasters were in florida they
were always around the corner like bad
storms uh
were you scared because you had heard
about them and you did the hall like we
had to do the training in the hallway or
had you been through one uh we had been
through one i guess or maybe my i went
to a place called bowman center in
carrollwood and a tornado rolled through
and on dale maybe we flipped a
a truck over and we were just off dale
mabry and they came in
you know i still to this day have like
real issues with when
actual panic happens in real life
meaning
you're at a pool and someone goes
where's my daughter where's my daughter
like that energy oh that energy cuts to
the core of me
and and and
and i i i i remember feeling i remember
being like that [ __ ] just shows up at
bowman center this lady just comes in
and goes there's a tornado and everyone
on the desk they flipped a truck over on
dale mabry and everyone's like mother
[ __ ] like i was thought
like what the [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
and then and then go to
oblivious to the fact we i go to first
grade and it's like a private school we
have to wear uniforms and i'm so [ __ ]
excited until i get there and my dad's
like uh he's like um
i get there and i was like where are you
gonna sit and he's like
i go this is my seat where's your seat
he's like i'm
i'm not here with you and i go he's like
they're not sleeping yeah and i was like
well i don't want to be here without you
and he was like
he's like it's called school this is
what you do my dad's a real so you
didn't have a kindergarten or preschool
or anything like that i did but but no
my mom was a teacher or something like
she was always in the other room or okay
it was just very like you always had a
security blanket yeah we had a
screwdriver in first grade my world was
[ __ ] rocked i mean
rocked
[ __ ]
flipped upside down this was my 911. i
mean
this was great
my dad says to me my dad says to me he
goes uh buddy you just got to make
friends and i was like i was like yeah i
don't i don't have any i don't want to
make friends i got friends you're my
friend stay with me and he goes my dad
says to me
here's the deal i'm going to be in the
parking lot in the van outside i'll stay
there all day okay if you need me just
come get me i was like
okay i can do that i can do that and he
was like all right cool and he just left
my dad just [ __ ] left
so i'm
middle of first grade like first you
know 15 minutes i just get up and go let
me just check the window and i just walk
over the window take a look out mrs
thompson was like where are you going
and i was like i'm just checking on my
dad i was like you know what i'm gonna
go run down and check on him i can't see
the nightclub yeah i can't see that i
can't see the van so i'm gonna go down
to the parking lot she's like you're not
going to the parking lot and i was like
no no my dad's on there i'll see you
there she's like your dad's not here and
i was like no he's there and then she
took me out to the railing no and there
was no van and i was like
i mean
and i walked back in and i went table to
table to everyone that's the desk going
our parents left us our fair parents
left us
what if we never see them again and now
everyone's like we're not seeing our
parents again
we may never see them again they said
they're gonna be back what if they don't
come back what if we're here forever
miss thompson's like [ __ ]
so she grabs me she puts me on her in a
desk at the front of the school in front
of facing the class
oh no not that and holds my hand and
teaches class holding my hand as i sob
cry staring for the entire [ __ ] day
so there it is brian callahan tried to
rescue me samantha dude
they like they're like you know hey man
calm down and i was like
and it was like that
it was like that for like my first
[ __ ] week week of first grade it was
panic
and and
i mean i was and then and then all of a
sudden i got out of it
and uh
and then all of a sudden it's like my
real part like the guy that i am inside
right like real burke ricer
the one that the one that was the
funniest guy in college the one that was
the funniest guy in high school the one
that got into stand up and didn't
understand how it worked but knew he was
funny that guy came out
like first grade i get
dressed like i'm like
i hear talent show and i'm like oh [ __ ]
yes
and i decide i'm gonna be kiss i'm going
to be gene simmons
and i'm going to [ __ ] because one of
my favorite things to do was air guitar
air guitar
sing and dance run around and flip
around in my underwear
and so i dress for school for the talent
show for school in my mom's leotards
um two leather two chain belts she had
uh do my own makeup it was like [ __ ]
seven in the morning do my homework with
a cape and and a pair of her boots and i
get in the car with my dad and he was
like
what the [ __ ] are you wearing
i was like talent show today and he was
like it was it's like in the middle of
the day and so i want to make sure i was
like set for it
but this is like who i really am in in
like the the
i think the reason like my friends
people like me is i am really this
person this is the guy who drinks a
gallon of kool-aid and doesn't realize
you're not supposed to drink a gallon of
water or like showers and pools and like
this is really who i am
and so
and like we're like people laugh at it
and then you're kind of lost while
they're laughing like if you look at
that gallon clip a gallon goulet clip
when tom starts laughing you can see
that i don't know why he's laughing at
first i'm like
and then i'm like oh [ __ ] this is kind
of weird like oh god damn it you can see
it in my eyes tom's laughing hard as
[ __ ] and i'm laughing with him so i'm
like confused
uh so we get to the talent show and uh
his name is daniel kaufman he was a kid
he was a little older than me he had a
violin they were backstage brian
callahan was my manager we were first
grade
he was with me and you just solo gene
like you don't have another you don't
have peter paul or ace with you bro i
didn't have a guitar
i
i just i just was like i was like i
remember this kid daniel cough i want to
say that's his real name daniel kaufman
was going to play the violin he was like
a [ __ ] fourth grader or something
and i was like [ __ ] savannah he's got
he's got a violin and he goes what are
you and i said um kiss
and he goes okay he's like what
instrument do you play and i was like
oh i don't have one he's like what are
you gonna play and i was like
i'm like like thinking like i didn't
think this through at all like i hadn't
planned a routine i just was like music
right now i get up there no i had the
record i had the record what's the song
what song you want to do i
want to rock it
all night and you're gonna play nothing
and party every day i mean
i know you keep on riding you you keep
all right yeah and i'm looking at a
[ __ ]
k through five going like because i
can't hear you
and they're just like
they're like we don't know that we're
not familiar with the lyrics
i was obsessed with kids we don't want
to hear you
yeah
and i just went out there and rocked out
sweated my makeup down brian callahan
gave me a hug you [ __ ] killed it and
i
and but i was like i was definitely the
guy that was like that went amazing
and everyone else was like he's a
[ __ ] idiot like that was that by the
way that that thread traveled through
like that went fantastic yeah and
everyone's like i'm not certain that you
saw the same fight we were doing but uh
but yeah that was like first grade then
and then i don't know i think i think i
was pretty regular like so you're a good
student
grade wise or no i i'm dyslexic so i've
always had a rea but not like textbook
dyslexic but dyslexic i don't know how
it works but i've always had a hard time
reading i've always had a hard time
reading out loud a really hard time
reading out loud talk to me about the
that or when you go around the room and
and you have to read out loud like where
you mean hold on hold on you mean
[ __ ] like david jermaine who
could kill it you're like dude what the
[ __ ] were you raised on a pirate ship
and you had to read them to sleep every
night how the [ __ ] can you do this so
well
there were guys
there were guys with lisps that were
better at it than me yeah and then they
go they go
uh bert and i go uh-huh and [ __ ]
panic i mean just panicking
oh start sweating
um okay okay and like i'd [ __ ] up words
like
through or thorough or just i mean to
this day
there's the other day they were like we
gotta get rid of all the tyranny that's
not the word i read we gotta get rid of
all the [ __ ] and i'm like what the
[ __ ] they put that on cnn how [ __ ]
dang how is that even allowed
the other day i walked into the i walked
into the kitchen i said to leanne oh
[ __ ] did you know mississippi is trying
to outlaw adoption she was like what
i go yeah mississippi's outlawing
adoption she goes abortion [ __ ]
oh so they want orphans okay okay they
want them all right yeah i i was
dyslexic and so your brain learns how to
work differently you learn cheats so
shortcuts i've learned from this show
that that's actually hereditary so who'd
passed it to you then do you ever have a
mom
i'm sure my dad i'm sure my dad my dad
is one of those people that
he likes
i mean this the right way
he likes
i don't know the right way to say this
because it's not an underdog and it's
not the loser
but my dad believes he's nothing
he'll always fail so it makes him work
harder and i think i inherited that
and somehow because like i don't think i
know for a fact i'm not the most
talented comic i've seen people perform
so when i get ready to do a special and
that's why i'm like blown away by very
talented people who go yeah i ran it i
went on the road last week i've been
running a little bit you know but yeah
i'm ready for it and you go you're ready
for a special and you did like three
weekends like i
have been on the road
every
single [ __ ] week
of this year except for
one
that since they opened it up and and i
have next week off that's a week off and
i have another week off but i'm on the
road and i add shows i'll do whatever i
can because i need to run the material
to get it good because i'm not as good
as chapel i'm just not man i watch this
special working out today i'm just never
going to be him that never will happen
but if i work hard enough maybe
people will be like oh that's
i also like bert also you know they're
gonna be the best you for yours yeah
that's it i'm never gonna be like i just
i have to work harder than everyone else
and i i need to do it a certain way but
yeah i that panic of
of school oh
i mean i couldn't do it i couldn't
they'd
read out loud
i couldn't but you say no
i would no i would read out loud and i
would and then just get mocked but i was
really good at memorizing [ __ ] and i was
a really good actor at a young age like
in fifth grade they took us on this like
as a touring company to do shakespeare
and i could memorize lines
instantaneously and like i mean
i'd have to have someone read them to me
which is really [ __ ] fascinating so
when we did the machine
like now i can't even see right cause
i'm like i i'm so old i can't see and
our director was making our scripts and
like little tiny things
so we get to set and i i couldn't see
the script and by the way i'm also
dyslexic so i'm saying the wrong words
anyway and so i had to have this serbian
lady anya
we would do rehearsal me mark my co-lead
we'd rehearse on this lady anya would
stand in for me and she would read my
lines to in a scene and i would hear
them or read them
and then the next time we would do
rehearsal i'd say them
next to her and she'd go you're missing
one and i or something and then after
that i was off book i was off book and i
couldn't i could remember i knew them
all and i knew long monologues i knew
like i knew it all and mark hamill
actually said to me you have an insane
he said to me one time because i also
wanted to change scripts because i was
like because i never was really married
to the script so i was like i was like
let's change the scene let's do this and
mark pulled me aside one time he goes
you have to understand you have an
insane ability to memorize that not
everyone has a lot of people have to
work
all night long to memorize their lines
you are drinking wine all night in
serbia going out running in the morning
not looking but i also wrote helped
write the scripture you know create
scripture i've been reading it for eight
months would you like have her read it
and then listen to her recording her
while you're running or anything no no
no she just read it right there she go
i am the machine
oh i want her father i love you i won it
was so [ __ ] hilarious she would go
her name was anya and she would go uh
she'll go i'm trying to think of one of
my lines um
daughter don't go you're acting like a
[ __ ]
and but it was she had the cutest accent
she was [ __ ] hilarious but that's how
it worked and that and that and that
all through high school i mean i never
never was a good student never could
figure out never was like i don't know i
remember people applying to colleges i
took the s.a.t
took the sat and i [ __ ] aced it and i
was like would you get [ __ ] like
13.50 or something
blew me away i remember the first time i
took it out i got 9 50 and then the next
and then i took a class to learn and
they taught you you know some tricks
next time i take it i [ __ ] aced it
applied to florida in florida state got
accepted florida state i was like i'm
done i'm done with school i go to
florida state and even all through
florida state i don't even know my never
studied for a test i just i never
studied for a test i never studied for
anything my entire life i've never
studied for anything because i just i
didn't know people would go like take
notes and i'd be like i don't know i
don't know what that means do you
remember like you get a notebook and sit
in class and they go miss christ you
taking notes i was like uh-huh and then
i write miss cruz are you taking notes
and i was like is that part of the notes
and then they'll be like
and then i'd start like uh like class
and then put a one and then an a under
that and be like i was supposed to go
there like i didn't know what to write
down i know the important things they
were saying
you ain't giving us dittos yeah yeah i
was always worried about that
yeah but but but what's interesting is i
was the [ __ ] i was a cool kid up
until eighth grade like cool kid in
eighth grade
sixth seventh grade only hung out with
older kids seventh grade hung out with
ninth graders
eighth grade hung out with ninth and
tenth graders what shifted were you good
at sports we were making everybody
really good sports i was really good at
sports no i didn't make anyone laugh i
was super serious almost oh really yeah
yeah like uh i was like a john what's
the not john winters not john what's the
[ __ ] guy who did all the movies in
the 80s pretty and pink and [ __ ]
waters john no no not john waters either
oh oh oh uh uh oh
shame on all of us uh of course yeah
he did i think he'd at home alone i
think he did everything 16 candles all
up i was like i was
i have a very very very deep romantic
side of me that
long to have a girlfriend long to be in
love and like longed for all of that
which i was ashamed of
and so i identified with those ducky
characters and and anthony michael hall
characters identified with that but i
was a cool kid i was great at sports
and this small school what shifted
um
was i went to an all boys catholic high
school and man that was like
that was like uh it was like day one get
your dick knocked in the dirt like
really i was like i mean
that was my oz like that was my like
that was my life
like that was when i was like i'm
in the big house now like
i mean you had bullies but i don't
understand i mean i know people have
bullies the same mean things to them
bullies would attack you or touch you or
[ __ ] assault you
um
like it was it was like i mean
i'm not making it worse than like it
needs i'm making it worse than it needs
to be like i'm telling you but like
[ __ ] some
[ __ ] senior would just come up and
just [ __ ] clothesline you and you'd
be on the ground unconsciously what
happened
or
like or like i remember one time i
walked in someone yelled food fight i
got hit with an apple and i was like
[ __ ] me that hurt
or or i remember one dude got my face
like he walked by and he bumped into one
of my friends and i started laughing and
then he comes back goes the [ __ ] you
laughing at he's like five six but he's
a senior and he was hairy and he was
like greasy he was like what the [ __ ]
you laughing at and i was like
i like an idiot i said you because i was
laughing at him yeah he flipped my food
in my lap and he was like get up
[ __ ] get up and i was like the
[ __ ] did i do what did i say what did i
say so like
it was like all of a sudden you're a
child where you were cool at one school
yeah
and now i sucked at sports because cuban
kids they were [ __ ] playing sports
yeah they were like [ __ ] yeah good
you were like how did you how did
everyone get so good at sports all of a
sudden like did you guys have parents
like why the [ __ ] are you so good
didn't make the basketball team didn't
make the baseball team had just had to
join the track team and the swimming
team because i was like i want to play
sports and i'm good but i'm just not i'm
like
like i wasn't like shaving yet like
everyone was shaving and i was just like
what the [ __ ]
but i had a good rat a really close
group of friends like like a
big group of friends i won't say their
names so i'm sure they don't want to be
associated with me as like is that born
out of like youth sports or is that like
middle school guys high school how how
far back do these dudes go
so
here's the interesting intersection i
played baseball pretty competitively my
whole life and we played a place called
forest hills
now everyone in the south now i mean i'm
i'm speaking across the board i don't
mean to i guess i know that when you say
something people can take it and have it
mean something else but i'm just saying
there was like rich kids baseball and
poor kids baseball this bart chrysler's
in sight okay
poor kids baseball was pony baseball
okay pony baseball was like you could
steal bases
kids could pitch
um
that's the league i played dad's prank i
mean the coaches smoked they smoked lean
over you're like come on this is how you
bunt god damn everything's burning my
eyes i remember playing third base for
the yankees i was
so if i was if i was six when i played
pinto i was maybe eight years old maybe
eight or eight years old
and i remember a coach
i remember two coaches
betting a steak dinner
that they could hit baseballs past me
and they're like he's in the hot box
chrysler get up on the grass i bet you i
bet you stick dinner i hit a ball past
chrysler and the guy was like steak
dinner you can't christy got a great
glove and i was like
and then these dudes these grown men
drunk just taking crap just yeah
and i'm like i caught it on accident i
wish i hadn't i want this bed to be over
but like that was so pony baseball now
in pony baseball you played uh
you played
i could be off on this but you mostly
played like the uh the dwight gooden
schools like over at hillsborough that
area i forget what i forget the name of
that belmont heights
um
i think that's the name of them you
played town and country which was more
cuban you played like you and then
forest hills was very redneck like very
redneck
and and a bunch of other places but that
was who you played and then the other
school the other people they they played
in the world series championship like
the kids that go to play in the world
series and my group of friends that i
played with grow all growing up all
played in
town country and then when we went to
public when we went to jesuit
all those dudes i've been playing
against in all-star tournaments my whole
life all went to jesuit okay so i knew
them i knew like brad radke ty rodriguez
um uh uh
fernando like i knew all these dudes
because we'd all been playing baseball
together and then all the kids that had
gone because you watched
our same age group who played the
different baseball the rich white kids
baseball they had gone and won the world
series in uh
it for youth baseball and so we watched
them so i knew all those guys too
so when we all went there all of a
sudden sports was like our thing
everyone knew sports and i had a big
group of friends i mean i'm talking
20 deep
of like
20 deep of just
of dudes i dudes i know to this day that
i talked to during this day that hit me
up when the pandemic started yo i own a
restaurant it's called the rooster in
the till hit me can you help me i help
my business out i'm doing takeout dudes
i know
i mean like my best friends for the rest
of my life
are all those guys
ninth grade tight as [ __ ]
they half of them go on to public school
and half of us stay there
and we just merged we took our group
became bigger and we took over all these
dudes that went to public school we
became best friends with their new
friends
and so all of a sudden you're looking at
a group of dudes
who to this day know each other very
intimately like i mean that's great um
and uh
i don't hear that a lot no i gotta i
like because well because it's also
tampa is a weird [ __ ] place
like you know i don't know it's not i
don't think our people understand how
[ __ ] up florida is is that like
this [ __ ]
i don't know you know it's just a weird
[ __ ] place and so
we all stayed and then and then and then
it doesn't hurt that
you know the majority of florida kids go
to florida state florida so florida
state florida is where we went and then
we just all keep hanging out i mean one
of the one of my best friends that i
grew up with
produces my specials oh is that right
yeah produces all my specials that's
great yeah and so uh
but i think
i think in high school i learned i
learned that freshman year when i didn't
have sports that i
had to have some sort of currency to
like get people to like me and that's
when i le i found
humor
because and and by the way definitely
where i learned how to tell the story
because
i remember practicing stories from mr
mark and dante's class to the lunchroom
like right running it
and going like you'd be telling these
kids
yeah i'd be running it on the walk and
being like okay
um well i got cayman's like we're gonna
do this beer run i'm like i don't wanna
[ __ ] do a beer run and he's like
don't worry be fine so he runs in all of
a sudden we're all sitting there and all
sudden he comes out we're like oh it's
fine he's like dog you know or like and
so you'd practice your story in a weird
way and then you sit at the lunch table
and you had to earn your spot at the
lunch table and
and and i'll i mean i look i don't
i like talking in absolutes and i know
this this is not you can't do that but
cuban kids tell the best [ __ ] stories
like just because they're [ __ ] i
remember dudes like their hands gestures
like
oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] guy i do imagine him being
not in your head it's like it's like
growing up with a bunch of joey diaz's a
bunch of joe ideas
and every
and so you i don't know you kind of
learn i don't know you learn how that
that works and i was funny in high
school but i was also pretty like still
the serious side of like trying to get
[ __ ] trying to play sports all right
how old were you when you lost your
virginity it's an interesting story i'm
talking about that am i special right
now are you in mine no no one at all 17
years old 17 years old and man i was in
a rush to lose this [ __ ] thing why
were you like the last of your group no
15 years old sit at the lunch table and
they tell us the story of of a dude
who had already [ __ ] and and we knew
him and i was like oh my god that's
gotta be [ __ ] amazing yeah and then
and then my friends started falling off
like they'd be like i lost my virginity
last night [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up was it
was freshman year
i dated a chick and i pressured her like
i mean like like on the phone we should
do it we should [ __ ] do it she was
like i'm not ready and i was like
and then we broke up
and then i did another chick and it
almost happened with her and it didn't
and then i did other chicks and i just
and then i didn't have like a girlfriend
i didn't like i i was someone who was
like gonna wanted to
be dating the chick i thought that was
cool
and then and then and then i and then i
dated a chicken
how old was she
she was 17 but she was she was like two
weeks older than me okay she was a year
older she had school same school no no
girls school year older i always thought
i was always so hot if i dated a girl
that wasn't at my high school i always
felt like a baller i'm like i'm dating a
girl from south carolina [ __ ] we
will never
we will never get back
that feeling no that feeling of of of
the girls school shows up
at when you're at practice
and you see the talent walk out and
you're just like
who the [ __ ] is that
and just going like what the [ __ ] and
everyone
being interested in the same
[ __ ] person
and then watching who lands it like it
was it was insane
but yeah i i i mean i've told the story
before but i will definitely tell you i
was not good my first time but no one is
anybody says they are as [ __ ] i bet
i'm worse than that person
[Laughter]
so me and my buddy jeff harley uh
get our girlfriends at the time
we'd go to one girl's dad had like a a
crash pad right clearly
guys guy's getting [ __ ] on the side he
hit a crash pack in carol woods so we go
go we go to her dad's house he's out of
town he's in mexico or whatever we go to
the heights house we get pet cemetery
and a case of natty light
and uh and in two condoms
i uh
immediately my chick's like hey and we
were dating we were dating and and uh
she was the [ __ ] coolest chick she
introduced me to the b-52s like she did
so much about this chick that's awesome
about this chick
and uh and and i hate that i'm sharing
this because if she ever hears this
she's gonna be like she's gonna be like
ugh
i feel so sad for him
we go in
we go in i
i i uh
i get on the bed we make out or whatever
and then i and then immediately i
realize it's gonna happen i'm taking my
clothes off and i'm like all right this
is gonna happen
i dropped my my feet i'm by the way i
have a i have uh a baseball jacket they
were like a pullover jacket with a
collar with a zipper right here yeah
with your name embroidered here i have a
baseball jacket on a hat i have shoes on
i have uh i have my jeans on i put my
jeans out of my ankles and i'm ready to
go that's how a naked i'm willing to get
i take my i take a condom out i take it
out i unroll it let me ask you this
prior to this had you ever put a condom
on your never exactly never why would
you ever put a condom on and never
practice i think it was santino i had
talked about this because all this
awkwardness that goes into this moment
you don't even think like
oh [ __ ] if i wha how's this go it gets
all sticky on your fingers it [ __ ]
stinks you're like well i don't even
know i don't know it smells like [ __ ]
yeah i i have tactile issues i've always
been i've always had a problem with
balloons
so the second i smell it
the second i smell it i'm like
like i'm [ __ ]
it's a nightmare so i take it i look
like i've never heard anybody say i've
always had a problem with blue ever
since i was a kid i've always had a
problem with blooms the smell of them
the feel of them the the [ __ ] fact
that they're unpredictable they can pop
at any moment
[ __ ] hate balloons i [ __ ] hate
balloons i've hated balloons my whole
[ __ ] life my whole [ __ ] life i
hated balloons and now i'm [ __ ] 17
years old and i gotta pull a balloon on
my dick
i remember the smell of it bothered me
so much it stinks
so much
oh
i remember thinking what kind of [ __ ]
animal wears a condom
i'd rather get aids than wear a [ __ ]
condom like and age is like i was like i
was like in my head i was like she
probably has aids because i thought
everyone had aids back tom and i talk
about this like our fathers they never
wore condoms they go get a [ __ ] shot
of penicillin or
stick it out or walk it off they never
got my fear
my fear at that time was aids right
now johnson's got aids we can all get
a's i'm gonna get aids right that's all
i thought about was aids all i thought
about was aids
so i i take kind of my shade it's rolled
up and then i'm like my mom rolls my
socks up okay so i unroll the condom
unroll it all the way and i'm like
that's
four inches of dick i don't need
so
so i rolled it back up four inches and
i'm like there we go that's more
suitable for me so wait you unrolled it
and thinking i gotta put my dick in it
then like a sock sure you're gonna slide
your dick in the unrolled thing yeah you
unroll it and then you slide you did not
put it at the tip of the hard one and
then roll it down i remember them
explaining condoms at some time you'd
hear someone explain condoms not a
jesuit a jesuit they they showed you in
freshman year a third trimester abortion
in religion class abortion on a tv they
showed you a third trimester abortion
who's filming that so that you wouldn't
have sex and if you did have sex and you
had a baby you would not kill it
i'm talking third trimester is where
they break it apart and pull it out
piece by piece oh no that is you saw
that do you want to talk about a pivot
you put a [ __ ] film up of a chick
getting in stir stirrups naked and
everyone's like whoa we're seeing [ __ ]
[Applause]
and then all of a sudden you're like
that's an arm
[ __ ] that's an arm
oh [ __ ] that's a leg oh that's a human
they're pulling out a human
it was [ __ ] rough dude that skull
would be shut down
third trimester abortion and i know
there's people that go burp blows
stories out of proportion this is not
i'll [ __ ] call someone right now
third trimester abortion in religion oh
my god yeah and so so that's why i was
just like i don't want to get someone
pregnant or i don't want to get a's i
want to get someone pregnant but i don't
think i had realized the anyway we get
back to the condom i slide i go to slide
it over and as i push down it fills up
with air
and i'm like huh because there's air
trapped in there
and i'm like i'm gonna push harder as i
go to push harder and use here like
either like a
or i'm trying to squeeze the air out and
it's just ballooning up like i'm making
balloon animals on the [ __ ] corner of
a bed i'm [ __ ] shaking it's cold okay
it's like december november i'm trying
to get this condom on and i'm just like
[ __ ] like i'm not even good at
this like i'm bad at this i should have
stopped right there and said tonight's
not tonight i should have known and i do
that since then i've had in my life i
realize if you start to tell a story and
someone cuts you off in the middle of
the story and you're a dinner party
historian wasn't meant to be told
you gotta fly find the momentum of life
and if it and if it stops you at a
certain point you gotta take those signs
i get out i throw the condom away i get
up i put my pants on i'll be right back
i left something in the other room go
over to hartley i was like handy i need
your condom he was like you're already
done and i was like no i haven't even
started he's like what happened to yours
i was like it's broken give me yours
gives me the condom i go back in
now now i remember hearing
pinch the reservoir tip i remember
hearing things like that and just
blowing past it like if someone told you
how to change a tire and then and you
just were like no no i i know i'll
figure it out i figured out and then you
got to change the tire you're like yo
what is the what is the jack like oh
that's the jack
so i pinched the reservoir tip i slide
it over
my dick and i remember putting it on i
was like that felt pretty good
you know i get did you have it on the
right way first the right way okay
because you know you put it on the wrong
way before you start wrong you're like
you're going under like a roll you gotta
unroll it and then flip it around
i go i get on top of her
maybe do a couple kisses or whatever
before had she lost her virginity
already are you both virgins no she's
not a virgin okay she's not a virgin so
you got a veteran and so and i apologize
if she's listening to this going like
wait how do you know i was like
word
part of the draw
[Applause]
i was i was i needed to get rid of yeah
you ever see the movie there will be
blood i was tired of drilling holes and
nothing showed
up i was like give me a [ __ ] plot
that you know has oil on it i'm ready
for oil brother they're all these
gimmicks that promise a great night's
sleep and i don't care what kind of
toppers there are or how heavy a blanket
is it's lipstick on a pig if you were
sleeping on a terrible mattress your
sleep will be terrible it's that simple
that's why i recommend sleeping on a
purple mattress that's because only
purple mattresses have the gel flex grid
it's a super stretchy ultra squishy
material that adapts and flexes around
pressure points and doesn't retain heat
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything thanks to the gel flex grid
purple mattresses bounce back as you
move and shift and you'll never have
that i'm stuck feeling people get with
memory foam right kirsten and her
husband here have one i've got one uh i
love it i sleep on it all the time my
daughter's room try your purple mattress
risk free with free shipping and returns
and financing is available too getting a
great night's sleep starts with having a
great mattress get a purple mattress go
to purple.com honeydew and use code
honeydew for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
honeydew code honeydew for 10 off any
order of 200 or more purple.com honeydew
promo code honeydew terms apply the new
year is here and there's no better way
to kick off 2022 than by making sure
you're feeling like your best self one
stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone and they
have incredible hydration flavors like
watermelon lemon lime strawberry pina
colada and more you guys know i love
liquid iv they wouldn't be here if we
didn't love them didn't use them we got
them for at the office we got them for
all the guests to come in i use mine at
home every day take one every day on
walks take it to the gym making sure i'm
getting my hydration what makes liquid
iv so effective the science of cellular
transport technology that's that ctt
y'all designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream liquid
iv is on a mission to change the world
and they have donated over 19 million
servings globally grab liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code honeydew at checkout that's 25 off
of anything you order when you use promo
code honeydew at liquidive.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidive.com
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the do
so uh
so i get on top of her
and this is probably real time i get on
top of her arms trembling i remember the
second i went in i went
that felt phenomenal mind you that's
with a condom with a condom i remember
going
[Music]
on the pull out
it's over done done
i look at her
because i was like we both i just
haven't realized when we both had
orgasms i guess that's how that works
and she looks confused and i'm like
huh
she goes um are you going to put it in
i looked down my dicks between her butt
cheek in the bed i didn't even put it in
here no i didn't even [ __ ] a person
that's a major [ __ ] person i didn't
even need her there's still a virgin
yeah i'm still a virgin i'm [ __ ]
[Music]
that
as
what do you say to that you try to cut
you how do you cover that up you don't
cover that up
no no you do you do you do no you do how
do you do that i mean i i mean i i feel
i
i'll tell you
you just push on you push forward and
you have sex with a condom that's been
compromised
and then your dick or you're young yeah
you're dick you're so yeah i think i had
another orgasm i was like [ __ ]
whatever like
by the way once i got to the [ __ ]
real deal once i sat in the cadillac i
was like oh okay this is totally
different than a pony hat this is oh
this is different than a bunch of bed
but this is even better like i think the
next one was like that too
and but then but then it's a mess down
there because it's been sloshing and i'm
like i got her [ __ ] pregnant i know i
got her pregnant i remember very vividly
there's so much that i'm leaving out of
this as an adult because i don't want to
have to relive these moments on the
internet for the rest of my life but
suffice to say this is for the young boy
that's listening to this that had a
nightmare of an experience that's like
i'm [ __ ] i [ __ ] it up i'm not good
at sex i'm never gonna i'm like it gets
better it gets a lot better
i remember
going
into that bathroom it was a guest
bathroom it wasn't a jack-and-jill
bathroom it's a guest bathroom it wasn't
attached to the bedroom
looking in the mirror and going what the
[ __ ] did you just do like going like
like i thought you were someone like
looking at yourself going i thought you
were someone else
i thought you i thought you would have
killed that and look at you just [ __ ]
look at you
but but i lost my virginity and i was
like that's all that i care about yeah
well the second one
and so i
i in the car turned it on i dropped her
off gave her a kiss it was like i'm cool
as [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] got in
the car turned on the music the song
colors came on and i was at college i am
a nightmare hold on to the 275 listen to
colors pumping my hand through a [ __ ]
sunroof going i [ __ ] did it
late in bed that night the sunroof of
what what are you driving home my mom's
cars bmw's one of the [ __ ] oh yeah
nice ride the old school where they
sloped down in the front the back old
school is a [ __ ] diesel too so we
just
get home lay in bed that night and
my brain starts now i always have
problems with anxiety but my brain
starts and it just gets away from me
and i mean
the way an anxiety attack works for
anyone within a matter
i'll give it 30 minutes within a matter
of 30 minutes i am a [ __ ] mess
i'm like i guarantee you i gotta
pregnant my privates i'm like so you're
worried about age you're not worried
about kids are you worried about
everything yeah i'm worried about kids
but but
i realize
that i have invited this into my life
that i
i know for i know one thing for certain
i was not ready
to have sex
because i am not ready for the
responsibilities of of full-blown aids
and a family and a family and a family
like but it's like so acutely on paper
for me like you do you
you have a [ __ ] baseball game against
town and country or against
tampa catholic next week what the [ __ ]
you gonna do when you get her pregnant
how are you gonna tell your parents are
they gonna let you play you got accepted
and i was in junior but like you want to
go to florida state you're not gonna go
to college you're not gonna have a life
you're not gonna all these things start
[ __ ] becoming like
like if i if if you if you think that uh
was it rose glasses rose colored glasses
everything looks better with colored
glasses if if i was looking out at
losing my virginity with rose colored
glasses the second i [ __ ] her
the rose-colored glasses went away and
it was like it was like you have no life
you're growing up you're gonna get a job
where does that anxiety come from you
said you always have where's that
anxiety
come from i gotta be honest with you and
this is gonna sound [ __ ] horrible but
i think growing up in florida
but what was is there a time period you
remember you know that something
happened where you were like
you know and then it's that laundry list
of all the future tripping is what it's
called no i don't i don't think so i
mean i think
i don't know i wish i had a i wish i
could do the deep dive so because i know
that's part of the recovery of anxiety
is finding the thing that gave you this
are your parents like that my dad is my
dad you learn from watching too you
seeing your dad go he's meticulous in
that way and worries about everything
worries about everything but but it also
doesn't in a weird way like but he
definitely my dad is a catastrophe
thinker
he sees three steps ahead of the problem
before the problem started or that
you've even started i remember one time
we went to uh costco
cosplus me and my wife and we bought a
an ottoman to put blankets in and we
just had island georgia were walking and
they were talking a little bit
and we brought it home and my dad goes
what the [ __ ] are you did you buy that
for and i said
for blankets and he goes no your [ __ ]
[ __ ] kids are gonna put each other in
there and they're going to suffocate
each other and they're going to die and
i went
it's for blankets and he goes no no no
no no
trust me
your [ __ ] [ __ ] kids are going to do
do an escape act put them in there they
won't be able to get them out they're
going to suffocate and die when you're
not looking and i went dad and as he
said that
georgia is standing on the ottoman she
goes guess where baby isla is and i'm
like ugh
and she's in the [ __ ] ottomans
no this is in this in our house we
so yeah i i uh
my dad's catastrophe thinker but i don't
remember him having anxiety as a kid but
that spiraling that happened
that was like the first
i remember she came to take me to um
outback steakhouse if she ever listens
to this
she's gonna go
she this is gonna be like
like uh when a serial killer writes a
book and he's like
i was gonna kill my next-door neighbor
but she gave me an apple one day and
they're gonna be like i don't even i
remember giving him an apple but i know
i was gonna die that day
she we went to go to outback steakhouse
um
and i was first time ever had a bloom
and onion
and it was the first time i was ever
acutely aware of someone's perfume
because she wore the same perfume that
she had worn yes colors by benetton
colors colors
she showed up in colors and she went and
gave gave me a hug and i smelled the
perfume and it reminded me of the night
i lost my virginity and i went to the
bathroom and i threw up you threw up i
threw up in the bathroom and i've never
been a guy that throws up i've never
been a guy that throws up um
like i don't throw up very easily and i
went right to the restroom
it triggered me and my panic started was
that the smell of the condom it was the
smell of this the smell of colors if i
smell it i get physically [ __ ] ill
because i remember that night of a
failure of losing my virginity that
[ __ ] catastrophe of losing my
virginity and all the anxiety that
followed i mean ryan
i my anxiety was so bad about it
that like i i remember telling my mom
i need you to know i lost my virginity
like i lost i lost my virginity and i
and i i'm really nervous
i can tell you where we were i mean i
can tell you where we were in the car i
remember everything about mine like i
remember like i remember being in the
car with my mom and she was like i knew
something was going on
she goes i remember i knew something was
going on i was like really she gave an
acting off the first anxiety attack i
had i wonder if the first like
full-blown panic attack from smoking
weed was probably before then okay but
but but this i mean i couldn't tether
the two
because they're they're different
anxiety attacks but the [ __ ]
once you lose control of it it starts
going and all these thoughts that you'd
never
thought of they become real and they
become real
and you go and by the way that it's it's
that's haunted me my whole adult life i
mean
from that point
i i mean
i mean it hasn't happened in a little
while but it happened
like uh like perfect example
i uh
you know i got docked right and so i get
a new phone number and then no one's got
my phone number
and then howie mandel comes over and he
tells he starts talking about anxiety
and ocd and stuff and i and i deal with
that [ __ ]
and i go i go
i remember thinking i haven't dealt with
this in a while i wonder if this is
going to trigger anything and then
random as [ __ ] someone calls on my oh my
old number it shows up on my computer on
facetime
and he goes what's that noise in the
room i go oh so i got doxed it's people
calling my number news people just call
your [ __ ] number and i go yeah
and he's like uh he was like what do
they want that's like i don't know they
just want to talk and he goes go get it
and so i go to get it but the call's
already ended
how he goes call him back and i go okay
so i call him back we do a little prank
would i get when we get done the we've
called the guy the guy's like who the
[ __ ] is he's now he's looking at having
mandela so it's funny
get done
and i realized that as i facetimed him
when i facetime them it comes from my
new number
this is the first person i've given my
new number to so i'm like [ __ ]
so i i
i dm him
i say hey
i i'm looking through now text messages
from my old number trying to find his
number
and i see one from another guy and it's
this guy that's a [ __ ] drama going on
in comedy i'm that i'm attached to and
i'm like oh [ __ ] i should reply to him i
replied to him i reply to the old guy
from my new number
i reply to him with the drama going on
the comedy that i'm involved with
and then i'm like [ __ ] then i
got to reply to the guys
and man my spiral started it started
because the the you know when when you
when you get doxxed there's a lot of
really cool people that reach out to you
they do they do they text you they i'm a
fan they faceted me two guys faced on me
this morning they had just gotten to
work they were [ __ ] in the orange
vests in a [ __ ] factory and they were
like [ __ ] he answered and then they
texted you've made our day that's great
you also get the absolute tremendous
pieces of [ __ ]
who for whatever reason they're broken
and they just
they say really nasty harassing things
about you like where you just go like i
don't need that in my life and now i
mean i don't go on like
for twitter i don't have twitter on my
phone i have it on um
i have it on uh so if i want to use it i
can go to safari it's just to send stuff
out
because it's so small when you pulled up
on my phone on safari it's too small for
me to read because i don't have my
glasses and i'm a dyslexic like look how
small this is
like you can't ever read that right so i
can't read what anyone says so it's
really [ __ ] perfect right so i don't
know what they say anyway so like i'm
like i can't see that so i'm like [ __ ]
it i just put information out and then
every now and then on my computer but
like
for them to have access to my pocket
where they can where it's a text and you
think it's a friend and it's like you're
exactly what you we thought you were a
[ __ ] celebrity hungry [ __ ]
all you care about is being famous or
and like stuff like we're kind of
accurate you know
no but it's like but it's like it's like
it's like people put that and then
you're like you're like and then it kind
of [ __ ] your day up and especially if
you're in a soft place
it can sting so i was like i get rid of
my number and then when that howie
mandel thing happened and then i sent
the my number like three different
people with the wrong messages of the
wrong people dude started a spiral that
was like [ __ ] rough to peel out of
and i was like
and i'm not working that weekend right
so like all this [ __ ] builds up
but the most specific i remember is
losing my virginity losing my virginity
and it's part of the reason can i ask
you this really quick i don't mean to
interrupt but
you've never looked at it like
you failed but then you rallied
and you got yourself back up and even in
those circumstances you still were able
to pull through and and deliver no i
never looked at it like that no no i
have a weird perfectionist thing i don't
know i don't know if i don't know if
it's ocd or if it's work ethic or
whatever like the way i work garyvee
says perfection is just another form of
procrastination
won't won't do it till it's perfect
won't do it no no no no no no no
or whatever yeah that's not mine so like
uh
priscilla our old dog
passed away
she had a knee problems
and i had a really hard time accepting
her having knee problems
i don't know i wanted perfection i
didn't want
georgia when she was a baby
preschool she fell and she cut her chin
and it's gonna whatever is you can
interpret whatever i'm saying as
whatever you want it to be i know that's
how the internet works
you need to interpret it as honesty
because i'm sharing
how my brain works
she had a cut uh
on her on her chin that was pretty bad
it was pretty aggressive
and they were like yeah she can have a
scar a pretty bad scar there and i would
not accept that i would not accept my
baby girl to have an aggressive scar on
her chin i just would not i
that
the way i'm saying it right now just it
[ __ ] me it [ __ ] with me
so every night
and every morning i would put my derma
on it and i'd put a band-aid on her chin
before she went to school
and i tell her baby if you don't keep a
band-aid on it's going to scar pretty
bad because the sun will hit it and
you're outside so do the best you can to
keep the band-aid on it's not a big deal
if the band-aid falls off but the more
you have it on the better it is
i was obsessive with this mederma i mean
i mean every night i put mederma and i'd
rub it in i'd really make sure it got
rubbed in
kid has no scar on her chin wow you
can't see it i mean i was scared from
the kids bullying her with the band-aid
on the chin
from there going hey frank hey nelly get
over here
are you about to say loot
and what's so funny is now if i if i
look for that scar you can see like a
remnant it's like a little white but
nobody who knew nobody would know ever
yeah if i see it and i go
i remember i remember i remember very
fondly
taking that's how i took care of my
daughter was like
uh you're not gonna have a scar but but
i'm also like that with like uh
with my my body of like of like i
remember one time
taking a [ __ ] and i saw stretch marks on
my thighs and i was like what the [ __ ]
and my heart sank and i was like it's
over it's over
it's over it's like what's over i was
perfect you're modeling you're perfect i
was perfect until now
i remember i remember i remember netflix
netflix put my stomach on the on the
billboard and i go that's not me
and they're like i'm a distorted vision
of what i am or whatever
but um
weird perfectionist when priscilla got
her knee surgery
i learned a lot from that dog because
when she first got her knee surgery i
was like
so what do we just i mean we're like
writing it off so we have a [ __ ] dog
that can't run you can't play with it
you can't give it love what you don't
realize is that
and this is what priscilla taught me and
i did not learn it before then was that
things just change a little bit and then
things are new
and you accept you learn to live with
the new things and then that's
your newness and then
and then and and then all of a sudden it
becomes it becomes just as good as the
first thing you had like and i i didn't
i it
took me a very long time
i mean like i have a scar on my foot
today that if i see it i feel a deep
sadness from my life i'm such a [ __ ]
up person i'm about to tell you
something you're gonna look at me and
think i'm [ __ ] out of my mind
i've had perfect feet my entire life
i love the way this starts perfect
perfect arches your toes are symmetrical
beautiful arches but actually when
people see my feet they go those are
dancers arches i'm not even joking by
the way i have beautiful eyes i have
beautiful feet i mean it like like iron
you're beautiful burp i mean people see
my feet they go god damn it those are
good-looking feet and i take pride in my
feet my feet are always tanned
yeah yeah oh yeah i take care of my toes
i tan my feet i got a pedicure two days
ago with my daughter you go i'll take oh
i used to go with my girls i've been
gone since the pandemic but what i i
mean i'll take some morning time in the
morning to do my gratitude work right in
my happiness journal and i'll keep my
feet out
like this like legs together like i'm on
a scooter so that the sun hits my feet
right so that when i wear my flip-flops
people go god damn you got his feet
i [ __ ] was drunk in a super bowl and
i cut my foot really bad one time
to the day to this day if i see that
scar i can see it no one else can see it
but i see it and i just go and i just go
knows before i was before george i got
hers
and i go god damn it man
i had the best feet in town until i had
the best i mean i have
i have legit great feet like i'm like go
online there's [ __ ] websites
dedicated on my feet i'm not even
[ __ ] around google burke right here's
feet it comes up it's on like
wickedfeet.com
i have great [ __ ] feet i believe and
i know people with bad feet like [ __ ]
you're gonna see some terrible feet oh i
have great [ __ ] feet my arches and my
toes are not like the first three are
good then the last two are much shorter
than the first three i mean what's great
maybe i'm also have a little bit of a
foot fetish so like
like i'm in i'm into feet like i watch
uh my feet are killing me
you pull i thought you pulled up no but
uh but so like there was a weird thing
with perfection and and and uh
and like and like especially with girls
i had a really hard time accepting a
flaw in a girl if i saw a flaw i
couldn't get past it
um like what
cellulite like you'd see like and by the
way now it's like
i mean i'm married to a woman for 20
years like i i [ __ ] love it i love a
little bit of a flaw on a woman but i
had to learn to get there and leanne was
the one that taught me how to get there
leanne just was like
i was like this is what i look like
like this is and and
leanne just is just doesn't give a [ __ ]
about anything no plastic surgery she's
like
she finds it
she finds strength in aging because she
goes this is what you're supposed to
look like
amen to that i really believe that if
most people left plastic surgery alone
and let aged just as they would that on
the other side of that plastic surgery
window they would look better in their
60s even 70s if they make it without
that [ __ ] frankenstein 60s 70s yes
but there's a [ __ ] window of 50s
where you can stretch it for a little
like i have a buddy a good friend um
whose wife got plastic surgery and she
looks [ __ ] phenomenal i've said it
through like [ __ ] every time i say i go
you look better than last time
jesus christ
yeah you look [ __ ] amazing all right
let me ask you this i'm gonna wrangle
this back here so we're going to skip
florida state because we know florida
state well i think that what it was
interesting about well go ahead go see i
mean skip it but yeah i want to know
what happened so you're in college you
do college i know you graduate college
and now you're out of college and
getting into the world of comedy and
everything else but also you're becoming
a parent and everything so how do you
balance this anxiety that's been coming
with you because as we change our
anxieties change you know now you've got
a home and children and pets and all
these things that you have to take care
of and that anxiety is not it's not like
buy burp it's just [ __ ] like okay now
i got some more [ __ ] to worry about and
think about and so how do you because
you are
literally a comedian a podcaster a tv
host i mean you do all these [ __ ]
things so how do you balance the anxiety
of each of these things with you know
are my kids safe are my kids healthy is
my family taken care of
i just
it's not so funny but i just married
leanne
she's the right woman
she doesn't see anxiety
she doesn't she'll let you know when
things are bad
she's like a pilot
you know yeah that's interesting the way
leanne operates with everything is like
uh hey ladies and gentlemen we're gonna
feel a little bit of turbulence it's not
that bad trust me i'll let you know if
it gets bad i'll actually put your
seatbelts on i'm gonna have the flight
attendant sit down and you're like but
is it gonna be bad or not and but you
but the tone of her voice
you're just like
the way she operates i mean like
we've had a couple things that have been
big in our family you know like ours um
that i didn't handle well i never handle
anything well i don't i just don't and
uh leanne kind of just
writes lets me spin out and then rights
my boat
very candidly i and i hope one day
georgia sees this and goes like her i
hope she doesn't see the first part
about me losing my virginity
but like uh but like i i've i've dropped
the ball a lot on georgia like i i and
it's that perfection thing
it's that is that
like uh like i
i don't want priscilla to have any
injuries i don't want george that i have
any flaws i want her to be the perfect
kid i want her to she is the perfect kid
she really is now i now i see that
better
like i
like i mean the first time i found out
georgia had lied to me
i was
devastated i mean i was like would she
lie but can you talk about it no no it
was just uh during the pandemic i'm sure
i've talked about this i'm sure i've
talked about somewhere but during the
pandemic
they were going bike rides and uh and
and it was just and i thought that's all
it was
or anyone i talked to was like yeah good
luck
and i and i was like you're staying
socially distant like i had rules in my
head
and they weren't saying so [ __ ] isn't
they're [ __ ] kids they're going to a
parking garage they're hanging out
they're bullshitting
and
i found out
leanne found out first and then i found
out later and and i just didn't handle
it well like i didn't
i was like i don't know i just never
thought that kid would lie to me like
but i lied to my parents all the time
right
and so i and so i i and like i remember
remember one time she was like uh i
wanna quit softball and i was like
that's not happening
when i was a kid if your dad told you
something wasn't happening that was how
that worked yeah no [ __ ] and she
she quit softball
you you told her and she did it so
you're not quitting softball that will
not happen it was during the pandemic
they weren't even going to practice
anyway
we just keep one another year on the
team who gives a [ __ ]
and she just is like a very
strong-minded person
who knows what she wants
it's a very great quality to have
knows what she wants and does it
her way
and was like i
i love you i respect you but i'm going
to do what i want to do
and i [ __ ] melt it down like i'm not
good at that [ __ ] i'm just not and and
uh
and leanne is the one who kind of allows
me to melt down and then pulls me aside
and is like
you're overreacting to this
and and then allows me to spiral out
with her
and then
in a couple days
makes me realize
uh oh [ __ ] it's it's not as bad as i
made it feel she's like yeah yeah she's
a great [ __ ] kid i mean the kid is
the real the kid really is a phenomenal
kid
she is doing nothing that i did in high
school nothing i mean we're talking the
[ __ ] i did in high school
not none of that is happening the amount
of lies i told my parents oh god is that
kid does not do it they doesn't do it
you you try to connect with her and she
connects with you like i never connected
with my [ __ ] mom and dad i never was
like looking for a connection like no
that wasn't important then right she's
just a great [ __ ] kid and i just
was way overbearing and it was the
pandemic i'm sure we were all a little
bit out of our minds my ocd was coming
in with all that [ __ ] but like
but yeah yeah uh leanne's the reason the
way i deal with it is leanne it's
[ __ ] leanne like leanne is just
she just takes care of everything i mean
everything do you know when we put a way
to put priscilla down and i talk about
this in my act right now when we had to
put brazil down i remember thinking
thank god she raised these kids and i
didn't like thank god i was on the road
because if i was like i was melting down
when we had to do it and leanne had them
processing emotion and being [ __ ]
adults and being like and taking care of
priscilla and loving on her all night
like i just was drinking whiskey [ __ ]
mad biting the inside of my lip going
like [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] dog dealer
i got this goddamn like
so like uh yeah it's leanne and and it's
liam leanne does all of it yeah
so what now
where you sit literally scares you the
most what gives you the most anxiety
what are you trying to fight death oh
without a doubt really yeah death
are you 47 49 are you yeah i'm about to
be 49 in march really right there with
you um death i wake up every morning
thinking about death i think i wake up
every morning though
at least you get to think about death
bro you ain't thinking about death
you're [ __ ] dead when you hear
that
i love when you hear that i love a
statement like that where you go you
wake up thinking about it
i think to myself one what do you think
about it
very very
very i'm sure you're specific with your
thoughts one day
i will be laying on a bed
oh hopefully i guess
and i'll be looking at my family
and
and i will know i can't stop this i
can't change this that it's happening
and then i'm going back to darkness
i don't know what's going to happen
i can't change it
i mean it [ __ ] me up and i think about
it every morning when i wake up i think
i think this is inevitable this is
inevitable it is inevitable it's not it
is like like like uh like cancer culture
it's not that bad when you compare it to
death like you go you go it's not it's
not it's not inevitable like nothing
yeah like that like i mean i can change
my act i can write different stories but
i i'm not personally because i'm i'm a
little bit oblivious to the to
i i think everyone understands things
are meant to be jokes that comes to my
show you know and and if the that's the
tax i have to pay is that people get
upset by a joke i tell that's fine all
my behaviors i've had sex with six uh
women so like
my behaviors are pretty pretty [ __ ]
transparent um i've said inappropriate
[ __ ] on uh all the time my whole life
but i'm also a comic like also when
you're 10 years 11 whatever it is in the
podcast you've definitely said some dumb
[ __ ] oh darn i've recorded hours hours
and hours of rogan where i'm just high
as [ __ ] saying [ __ ] crazy if that comes
out i i want to say that the people that
come to my shows will side with me and
go hey man like that's that's how i
think is like if you're not hurting
someone if you're not doing something
malicious to someone or or
misrepresenting yourself in a certain
way i mean everyone knows how [ __ ]
flawed i am they've seen all the the
things i've said or whatever
so
but i don't really like i don't like i
don't think about
that because it isn't it isn't
inevitable but what you're saying to me
is inevitable yeah but what you're
saying to me is
in a bed surrounded by family so do you
see yourself older
oh he's how old's your dad your dad's
still alive 72. and you're you said your
grand your grandparents lived to what
like 99
a week a week before yeah what's that is
that mickey mouse it's not mickey mouse
it's that mickey mantle jean is like i
believe he's like i get up every morning
i work out and
like i worked out hard this morning
four miles a four mile run and then
lifted weights i'll do the same thing i
woke up so my thing now is like you know
that's not instagram stories
so i'm sitting in bed thinking about
death
and i go
you're not gonna get me today like let's
[ __ ] get on instagram stories you
just do one story and then all of a
sudden your day is started and you're
out of that bed
um
yeah i think about
i've always thought about death i think
i think now i think about it more
because i start seeing it quite
quantified i go
to 20 years it doesn't seem like a lot
let's put 20 years
like 30 sounds 30 i'd be 80. like what
the hell is i'm making it to 80. and
that's in this business yeah it's like
and then and then you see you hear
stories of like some dude 35 years old
eye cancer or whatever whatever but like
my dad died at 42 and i try to i'm for
about to be 49 i try
to remember that and be like
i won
yeah my my [ __ ] ain't doing
anything i was doing it my grandfather
died
my grandfathers both died early of
strokes
um so i got but i got in front of that
by getting a cardiologist
getting on blood pressure medicine
getting cte ct scans ct scans
all the work all the work stress tests i
do it i do it every nine months okay i
do it twice a year i do every year yeah
and so i do that i do physicals once
every year
um i do i'm i'm up with that but you
know still it's like i i'm a
cardiologist one day and he was like uh
you're still drinking i was like yeah
and he's like
you know that's gotta stop right he's
like you know that does it only ends one
way like and then the other day like my
neighbor our neighbor from our old house
she was like
this woman partied and i kind of got a
kick out of it she had a box of white
wine and just [ __ ] sit in the front
and just
and then leanne told me she was younger
than my parents and by the way now she's
having a rough time they have to carry
her with a belt like it's and i don't
need a belt like they put a [ __ ]
weight
[ __ ] belt around her and make sure
she can walk straight because oh it's
dude it's bad
and then you start going away yeah so
that's why i'm drinking [ __ ] fit vine
right now because because this [ __ ]
doesn't have the tannins in it doesn't
have the sugar so you're not hungover so
you can get up and do the work now great
and you don't get as drunk sorry fidvine
you don't get as drunk as you would but
that's all i want to do is have a couple
glasses of water my buddy and have a
conversation and so uh so yeah i i think
i think about
i think about health
consistently i think about longevity i
think about
uh i think about like like just i don't
want to die that's number one thing
the drinking is smoking let's say how
are you gonna stop when it's time when
that doctor says because oh it's going
to start it's going to happen before
then no one's going no no one will ever
tell here's what you're not going to
you're telling me that one your checkups
are not going to tell you bert no more
you're going to stop before they tell
you no one will tell me to quit drinking
that meaning meaning meaning uh you'll
stop before someone has to alert you of
your health is that what you're saying
so i've already made some
i mean
i've already made bigger leaps in in
watching my drinking than i ever have in
my life but before when we before we
started sober october i was drinking
aggressively and i was unaware
and this is going to sound [ __ ] crazy
but i was unaware that like day drinking
catches up to you meaning i couldn't
understand why i'd i'd be so hungover on
a monday when i'd partied all through
the weekend
and just and just rebounded you know
rebounded every day and then monday also
my back hurt and i'm like
but god damn it man i don't feel right i
feel off i'm like i'm sweating it smells
like piss and then
and then one day i just i just was like
oh that's that's that's day drinking
that's like getting on a plane and
flying and drinking all day i was like
okay all right
and so i just was like we have to adjust
because one of the things i love is
working out and so a lot of it happened
in serbia when we were doing the movie i
kind of really adjusted the way i drank
and was like
listen man if you want to open up a
bottle of wine every night that's fine
because it's way better than what i was
doing before right
but
but it stops at a bottle of wine you're
done in a bottle of wine uh you got to
work out in the morning you got to drink
water you got to take vitamins you got
to like there's it was all covered stuff
like i didn't drink kobe started i
didn't drink the first three months of
kovid is that right yeah cause i was
like i was like i [ __ ] feel like
[ __ ] great but like who cares
let me tell you something
out of covet that all i remember is that
first beer i had i remember first beer i
had we were at the new house we had to
stop construction because of covid right
so we i'm eating [ __ ] money on this
house
i hadn't drank in three months
we're over the new house the dog
priscilla's alive dogs are in the
backyard girls are still little girls
george and i hadn't gotten into a dust
up yet
i mean they were still my little girls
like we have bows and arrows set up we
had all these cool things we get over
there they're like my little girls
leanne comes over with a
straight up german craft brew
you know the tall ones the yeah the ones
that are like
not 32 ounces but like
way more than just a regular can of beer
she goes on a beer you want a beer and i
was like
i'm not drinking
she goes [ __ ] it have a beer
i was like for real excuse me i have a
beer have a beer
and i
and i i
i went and i got two i was like i'm not
gonna
i was like yeah because i want the bus i
want to feel the i want to feel the beer
buzz in the afternoon
with this this is the birth christian
i'm talking to so after three months of
no alcohol will two two of those beers
will give you a buzz kick me in the dick
really and it makes the trees sparkle
i mean
every time i quit drinking that first
drink
is i mean i have i have beautiful
thoughts
about life that first drink that first
drink i remember the first sober october
we did i was sober for what 31 days i
was gonna say man what is that like it's
f i love it i love it it's great if you
feel [ __ ] awesome the first drink
after 30 well it was only 30. this is
three months you're saying yeah there
was yeah yeah so i we
we uh is that the longest span of time
you've covered it's a long expensive
time because i had no work how many
years
three months and how many years
since russia
russia's when it got bad russia is when
it started yeah yeah russia is when i
was like oh you can drink in the
afternoon and they're like yeah of
course i was like sweet what happens
like just don't tell anybody i was like
don't tell anybody this is awesome
so i uh
i remember when we did sober october
there was this little girl
uh i won't say her name but there was
this little girl that used to come to
our house when we the girls were babe
young and she would dance and i was like
and by the way she'd just start dancing
and we're all watching a movie and the
kid would get up and start dancing i
remember saying to her dad her dad's
like a cool dude right i said do what's
up with your [ __ ] kid like she just
dances and goes i don't know man kid
just dances she [ __ ] it's like all of
a sudden she just gets this feeling and
she gets happy and
she's going away because she can express
it is dancing i can't explain it i was
like what whatever i don't get it
sober october
ends me and arya in new orleans we're
getting ready to do the joker's cruise
and uh
and me and already get cocktails
down the thing and and it doesn't taste
good but not enjoyable it's at the
carousel bar in new orleans
and then we do a shot
and we get another like a road cocktail
and as i step out of that whatever rest
hotel that has a carousel bar
i get into the street and my and and
it's new orleans i mean [ __ ] one of
the greatest cities in the goddamn yeah
everything's happening everything's
there everyone's laughing everyone's
cheering ari turns around smiling and he
goes i love this
and my alcohol kicks in and i feel my
first buzz in a month now mind you i've
been on a tear for a few years and now i
feel my first buzz in a month
and i realized why that little girl
danced i went i'm i started dancing i
was like this feels so [ __ ] good i
just want to dance i know it like this
is what she felt
she's so pure when you're a kid you're
so pure that you feel as a kid that you
start dancing and i go oh god damn it i
wanted to call her dad and be like yo
put your daughter on the phone i know
why the [ __ ] you dance yeah like and so
uh so like that's i've said it before
it's why i'll never i'll never i'll
never quit drinking about never let my
body get to the place where someone
tells me i have to stop drinking because
i don't want because i really enjoy it
it's like you know it's like it's like
the reason i'll never it's selfish the
reason i'll never cheat on the end not
because i give a [ __ ] about her feelings
i don't i don't i mean like i don't
they're not my feelings like i don't
feel what she feels
but but i need her in my life
so i selfishly
i i
i don't do things that everyone will
want to do chick wants to [ __ ] you after
a show and everyone wants to do that
like it would be feel great but i don't
do it i don't do it because i need that
woman in my life because without that
woman i don't have a house my kids are a
[ __ ] mess i probably don't have a car
payment like i have no way of getting
home today like i mean
like there's a [ __ ] lot like i
couldn't do anything without that woman
so like everything i do is selfish and
so
when i work out i don't like working out
like i hate it i do it every [ __ ]
morning
i i i don't eat great but when i eat
good it's so that i can eat like [ __ ]
later and get a [ __ ] suitcase of
white castles at two in the morning i'm
the same way i like let me lose 10
pounds nah [ __ ] that let me lose 15 so i
can [ __ ] off for a couple dudes i do
crazy [ __ ] diets to lose weight so i
can go party yeah i don't i don't drink
and work out so that i can drink and not
work out
like i mean i i i'm going back tonight
tonight i'll open up another bottle of
fit vine and get on the in the treadmill
and i'll walk like seven miles and have
a bottle of wine it's my greatest
it's like the [ __ ] and i go hey it's
just
i drink water like crazy i don't
i don't enjoy it that's why i love
[ __ ] liquid death you just murder
that [ __ ] i'm no one like i don't know i
like kool-aid i like kool-aid
but i drink water that's what i grew up
on kool-aid and country time lemonade
the powder and the [ __ ] jugs have you
had kool-aid at a soul food restaurant
no i haven't
it's got to be the emotion it's sugary
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's made the way it's
supposed to be made yeah like with
someone's hand
i just had went to a soul food
restaurant in new mexico
and they [ __ ] brought me kool-aid as
a joke they were like we know who you
are here's some kool-aid
if [ __ ] tasted like that kool-aid
i'd have bruised knees i mean [ __ ] off
oh [ __ ] i will say this i forgot this
i'm with eva one night and uh this is
probably and her brother this is right
around christmas time
and uh i call benihana i'm like hey you
guys happen to be open by any chance
we're in it we're right down the street
he's like we are open i said all right
so we go in
and we sit down and the guy's looking at
him and everything he comes up and he
sets a kool-aid down and he goes tell
the machine we said hello i said that's
[ __ ] ridiculous by the way by the way
can i tell you all that i heard out of
that story is
is this statement benny han has never
lost on me
if you you are i'm a betty hana guy i'm
a penny
i'm a terrible listener all i heard was
benny hannah and oh i thought you go to
[ __ ] penny hannah i love penny hannah
anything with a little bit of razzle
dazzle yeah and i am [ __ ] all in you
give me a fishbowl drink i love a
fishbowl drink i love a fishbowl drink
more than i like a regular drink if you
serve water and fish bowls i'd probably
drink it better did i ever tell you
about the time i drank our fishbowl
water one time what do you mean [ __ ]
leanne
is cleaning out our [ __ ] the girl's
fishbowl and she pours it in a pitcher
of water and i was like huh i could be
hydrated here we go and i drank the
fishes
fishbowl wall i drink all of it
and she was laughing
she's so [ __ ] hard and she was like
i just see those squigglies
like i was i was tall i go why would you
save the fish more water
why would you yeah she was like she was
uh she was
[ __ ] ph balancing it i drank the
whole [ __ ] thing oh god that is
disgusting
tonight i can feel it
[Laughter]
sativa i like sativa i'm a thinker i'm
not a that's that's what you want it's
not a brand for me it's more of the the
type of i like a giggle i love the
giggles sativa bro so my favorite thing
when i go to even the daytime high they
call indica couch lock that's your night
time that's the stuff you want to smoke
and you're like you know what [ __ ] all
our plans lay down me i'm like let's
[ __ ] paint the walls let's put some
pictures up over here let's paint let's
do this let's do that let's go clean
some [ __ ] yeah i'm i'm a i just want to
giggle
and not think about
i don't want to [ __ ]
oh
we got to get out of here but let me
because you have [ __ ] to do let me ask
you this question i ask everybody their
first time on here
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self after what we've talked about
right now today
and it can be funny it can be serious
whatever you want what what are you
going to say to 16 year old bert
kreischer knowing what you know now
[ __ ] slow down
i would really i would say slow the [ __ ]
down dude like you're in a rush to get
everything you don't know that you want
you don't need it
i mean every part of my life the [ __ ]
losing my virginity
uh
i made i made decisions based on what
people were making around me and then
even still like getting into comedy i
moved straight to new york and then in
comedy i was like i wanted everything
everyone else had
because and i didn't deserve it but i
didn't know it and i was like and i
would allow that to affect the way i
felt about myself and i would just say
slow the [ __ ] down i mean
slow the [ __ ] down i think that's great
i think it's great advice yeah you
always want
i've learned that too one of the things
that took me i mean well into my 40s to
learn is like
if you just [ __ ] take your foot off
the gas shut your [ __ ] mouth and sit
back it most of the time it takes care
of itself
the hardest thing to do is still tom
petty said man the waiting's the hardest
part you just [ __ ] get antsy like nah
i gotta do something here i gotta do
something i don't i didn't think i'd
realized that i would be this happy at
49 me either like really i thought about
it today like my dad again died at 42
and i'm like
[ __ ] didn't start happening for me until
47
40 46 47 probably same here oh my god i
could have died and never even hit my
potential or
started to hit my potential i get dawned
on i'm like god i think about that i
definitely think about that sometimes i
go how many times i could have died or
should have died and every person on
this planet is lucky to be make it past
16. the dumb [ __ ] we all do as kids
it's crazy but like if i i wish there
was a way i could go back and go like
hey
you're not going to
turn into who you want to be until
you're 49.
like you're going to be a stuttering
low ego low self-esteem having [ __ ] at
parties like
shut the [ __ ] up don't talk don't pitch
everyone your [ __ ] stupid ideas like
stop self-fucking if i ran back to my 16
year old self and hear me talking to the
party i would walk up and punch myself
in the face and be like who's that adult
that just came in here and punched ryan
in the face like his future
[ __ ] self wouldn't that be cool
like if you get to hang out with someone
who has the fl like if they compare you
right and you could go this is what's
wrong with me
like a tender right
so you go on and you these this is what
i don't like about me i died [ __ ] i
have low self-esteem i end up by
flawless yeah yeah yeah and then and
then they pair you with a guy a little
bit younger than you like by five years
ten years he has all your flaws and then
you get to be friends with him he
doesn't know why you're friends with him
you just get to see the thing you don't
like and you actualize
was interesting and then you were like
oh [ __ ] that's what i sound like i think
it's danish and o'neill i want to give
them credit if it is they had this idea
i heard about a while ago and i've
talked to them i'm almost positive it's
them but they they wrote this script
where
they time travel and they go back to
their meet their 17 year old selves to
tell them some [ __ ] that could change
their whole lives in the future yeah but
the time machine breaks and now they're
stuck with their 17 year old selves and
they [ __ ] can't stand them
and i think that is brilliant like could
you imagine
seriously being stuck for a month with
17 year old burke i could not so wait so
you know i wrote a script about
about my daughter's time traveling from
the future to come back to save leanne's
life okay
and they they come to pat's the local
bar yeah yeah yeah and they're like uh
they're like [ __ ] super proud of
themselves i don't know who they are and
they're like
what you're drinking cheetos is sort of
a big glass no lime
i said yeah like uh
what'd you have for dinner breakfast
tacos i was like do i know you guys and
they're like
it's george and isla and i'm like
what and they're like we saved mom's
life and i'm like what are you doing
like 25.
it's like yeah we time traveled we saved
mom's life and i'm gonna shut the [ __ ]
up
and i'm like wait are you guys
scientists and they're like no i'm a dj
she's i'm i'm i'm her manager
she's my manager
and i go wait how he goes right back
you guys time travel and they're like we
got this calendar at this like gypsy
stop and uh we can drive travel and i
was like what about butterfly effects
and they're like huh
like what like did you change the future
and they're like i don't know what
you're talking about and they're just
the morons they are today right but
they're just as dumb in the future and
they come back and they end up
falling in love with them young their
young cells and their young cells fall
in love with them and they [ __ ] up the
entire future for everyone because
they go and grab them and take them out
of school and go party with them for a
day yeah and i was like and it's so
funny because
i sent that script i pitched it a couple
places and then and then you know the
scriptures go away whatever but uh but i
love i'm obsessed with time travel i
think so i'm afraid of death yeah any
more questions
brother just promote whatever you'd like
to promote we'll get out of here um
here's what i'd like to promote
i've shared everything with you okay i'm
looking at the camera right now shared
i've shared everything with you
uh you will
see a very vulnerable side of me i'm
sure
in the future
in my movie the machine
because i'm going to promote it i really
want everyone to see it
and and when's it supposed to i don't
know i don't know but but i i will i
will be going hard in the paint
promoting this thing it's coming back
you get one shot in life something like
this i'm going to be going out hard as
[ __ ] to promote this thing
okay that's the and i know podcast fans
are like dude enough we get it like you
guys are so inside baseball
all i ask is that you help me promote it
if you see a trailer for you retweet it
you talk kindly of it you go out and see
it
uh and just be cool i hope you enjoy it
like
it's great i love it i got luke
skywalker i know it's it's great but
like but i know podcast fans are
discerning [ __ ] like i know
because i'm one
and i [ __ ] catch myself talking [ __ ]
about people but still they're also
diehard [ __ ] yeah and they
support hard as [ __ ] they go hard in the
past well i just hope that when that
movie comes out that you enjoy it that
you spread the word that's the only
thing is that i i will be going hard
you'll see me on everyone's podcast
don't be like jesus christ there's bird
on everyone's [ __ ] podcast because
that's what i say that's what i say i go
well what the [ __ ] he promoted he's on
tim dillon he's on ryan sickler he's on
[ __ ] your mom's house joe rogan jesus
christ bird [ __ ] dick boy studios are
you [ __ ] serious we got it your
[ __ ] movie's coming out
be cool okay be cool and just and just
support my movie the machine that will
be coming out and and i hope everyone
enjoys it i'm really excited i'm really
i'm really excited i love you bro i love
you i love you more
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you